mesdames et messieurs bonjour nous
sommes dans un monde de plus en plus
concurrentiel le contexte économique est
difficile
pour être compétitif il faut gagner en
performance collective et pour gagner en
performance
il faut mettre en oeuvre des techniques
managériales adapté et innovante en
sport comme dans le monde économique
il ya toujours plus d'acteurs toujours
meilleur toujours plus jeunes mieux
préparés avec du matériel toujours plus
précis plus performant
aujourd'hui je suis venu vous parler de
quelque chose qui me tient très à coeur
quelque chose que j'ai envie de partager
avec vous osez la singularité et même
plus que ça assumer sa singularité
alors qu'est ce que c'est que la
singularité
c'est ce qu'on a tous c'est ce petit
truc en plus qui fait la différence
ces petites choses qui nous rend si
singulier alors je vais vous raconter au
travers mon parcours mes expériences et
tout ce que j'ai vécu
comment cette singularité m'a permis
d'avoir plus de performance elle m'a
permis de gagner des coupes du monde
quand j'étais petit
même encore aujourd'hui je suis
quelqu'un d'assez discret a pas beaucoup
confiance en soi qui est qui observe
qu'ils essayent qui se pose toujours
beaucoup de questions je fais pas partie
des ambitieux je fais pas partie des
optimistes
et quand j'étais petite je rêvais d'être
championne j'adorerais gagner des
compètes mais j'avais toujours très très
peur et je pensais pas que je serais
capable d'y arriver
en tout cas je me voyais pas comme la
future championne et pourtant je suis
arrivé jusque là où je suis arrivé
jusqu'au plus haut niveau
tout commence en 99 j'ai 17 ans c'est ma
première sélection dans les équipes de
france
le groupe horizon 2002 horizon 2002
parce que c'est un groupe qui nous
préparait pour les jeux olympiques de
salt lake city en 2002 douze filles 12
talent
les futurs talents les futures
championnes de demain
alors à cette époque là je faisais
partie défi qui dormait ski qui manger
ce qu'ils vivent à skis je vous laisse
imaginer dans quel état d'excitation se
trouve à ce moment là et pourtant
première désillusion une seule méthode
d'entraînement une seule préparation
physique
une seule technique appliquée à tout et
moi sandrine aubert qui croyaient que
j'étais particulière que j'avais quelque
chose de plus mais non j'étais comme les
autres alors j'applique la méthode comme
tout le monde
m'appuie sur les skis faite de haut et
entièrement et adieu ma singularité
résultat de tout ça on progresse tout
mais pas l'auteur nos espérances on
gagne des compétitions mais pas la
hauteur nos attentes et aucune d'entre
nous va aux jeux olympiques le sentiment
que j'ai eu en 2002 s'est encore fait
une croix sur ma singularité et
finalement en suivant un modèle de
performance qui n'a pas porté ses fruits
et c'est à ce moment là que je me dis il
faut que je trouve mon truc en plus il
faut que je trouve ce qui fait la
différence et ce qui va me permettre de
sortir de la masse j'ai la chance de
tomber sur un entraîneur qui lui est
singulier et qui lui va nous permettre
d'oser d'oser s'exprimer se servir nos
atouts alors dans l'imaginaire de tout
le monde la skieuse
c'est quelqu'un qui est plutôt compact
qui est plutôt puissant si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire et qui est très
agressif qui est combatif et moi eh ben
je fais pas en partie la norme chez des
jambes plus longues que la moyenne
puis j'ai pas tellement le caractère
combatif alors j'ai passé des années à
me battre contre ça parce que je pensais
que c'était un handicap
je pensais que c'était un défaut donc on
a essayé de le corriger alors chez
manger des protéines pour grossir un peu
j'ai essayé de faire beaucoup de muscu
pour être plus compacts pour être plus
puissante
tu es aussi fait le tour des
préparateurs mentaux pour être plus
combatifs plus méchante mais ça n'a pas
tellement porté ses fruits du coup grâce
à cet entraîneur on s'est dit qu'est ce
que j'ai qu'est ce que j'ai de plus et
ben j'ai fait ce corps à ses jambes il
faut savoir que ma discipline c'était
seulement le salam
c'est un parcours sur une piste enneigée
d'un point a à un point b faut aller
plus vite possible d'en haut en bas et
au milieu il ya des des piquets donc ça
fait des sales homme comme ça et le but
passé darier plus possible de passer les
pieds autour comme ça et puis de gagner
plus possible de vitesse alors
normalement de ski je pense que vous
avez vu de trois sketches auparavant au
ski le ski c'est petit à petit comme ça
appuie fort sur les skis mais bon je
n'arrivais pas très bien et du coup on
s'est servi de ses jambons on s'est dit
tu vas apprendre plus d'amplitude tu vas
aller chercher juste avec les pieds en
gardant le corps au milieu vient centrer
et grâce à ça je vais gagner en
efficacité et du coup en rapidité
grâce à cette technique je vais pas
céder des top 10 en coupe d'europe au
podium puis des podiums aux victoires en
2006 je termine championne d'europe de
la discipline du slalom
et si mon entraîneur et pas su exploiter
cette singularité ses jambes ce
caractère un peu plus fluide mais je
pense pas que j'aurai atteint ce niveau
là alors ensuite je continue à
progresser
j'enchaîne les victoires en coupe
d'europe je progresse au classement
mondial je suis 20e mondiale et donc j'y
intègre le groupe coupe du monde
le groupe élite de la fédération
française de ski là aussi ça c'est un
grand pas du coup je me retrouve avec
des filles qui ont gagné les coupes du
monde qui ont été championnes olympiques
ont gagné des coptes globe de cristal la
plus haute récompense dans notre
discipline
alors qu'est ce que je fais je copie
j'essaye de m'inspirer de ce qu'elles
font
j'essaye de faire pareil je me dis c'est
le fond comme ça c'est qu'il faut faire
comme ça donc je me remets à skier tic
et tac
puis sur mes skis je fais de la muscu
annonça sa marche pas très bien je
recommence à stagner
je commence à douter de moi et encore
une fois la spirale qui redescend
encore une fois je vais avoir la chance
d'avoir des entraîneurs qui se penche
sur mon cas qui se disent mais comment
on va faire pour qu'elle retrouve un
petit peu son ski sa manière d'être
cet entraîneur va m'orienter vers une
nouvelle discipline qui s'appelle le
super combiné super combiné c'est
l'association des deux disciplines les
plus extrêmes du ski alpin le slalom ma
discipline et la descente alors la
descente le matin ont commencé par ça
c'est super pour ce matin d'appétit la
descente ça fait deux minutes à peu près
temps et puis c'est sur les pistes
vertigineuse il ya la neige
allez je les ai tellement je les conçois
sedan on voit les bâches
j'imaginais quand on fait les virages
bon il ya la page qui nous attend au
bout là bas et puis ça va super vite
quoi alors il ya des filles comme
lindsey vonn qui prenait des positions
aérodynamiques comme celle là pour aller
plus vite possible pour absorber les
mouvements de terrain pour gagner de la
vitesse
puis on est des filles comme moi qui
étais là pour arriver en boivent surtout
que tout se passe bien
donc la position c'était plutôt une
position bayrou dynamique comme ça avec
le pied qui tape là la bâche là-bas à
pied ça peut arriver
1 parce que en écartant les coûts' a
perdu 36 ça m'a valu sa venue selon
bambi je pense que bon bein ça m'allait
bien
voilà ça tout ça pour vous dire que
j'étais dans un état de stress permanent
et c'est ce que recherchait mon
entraîneur parce qu'il voulait il
voulait me sortir de ma zone de confort
ils voulaient me poussée dans mes
retranchements
je vous garantis qu'à ce moment là
j'étais bien dans mes retranchements à
130 kilomètres heure 125 pour moi c'est
bon hop les ailes ou le pied droit ça
l'est un peu moins vite déjà mais quand
même et je quand on est dans cet état là
bas on arrive plus
pis la voisine parce que on est
tellement stressée quoi on a plus
d'idées quoi donc est ce qu'on se fait
bon se sert de ce qu'on sait faire et
c'est grâce à ça que je me suis
reconcentré sur ce que je savais faire
ma technique mes jambes beaucoup
d'amplitude beaucoup de mouvements
beaucoup de touches neiges et grâce à ça
dans l'après-midi à l'épreuve du salon
vous rappelle que c'est le combiné des
deux j'arrivais à m'exprimer à nouveau
j'arrivais à faire de beaux virages à
jouer avec mes jambes
et voilà j'ai recommencé à progresser je
suis 4e mondial à la fin de la saison de
cette discipline
l'année suivante ils gagnent de coupe du
monde
j'enchaîne encore l'année d'après avec
deux nouvelles victoires ce qui me
propulse leader mondial de la discipline
en janvier 2000 2010 alors je vous pose
la question est ce que j'aurai réussi
tout ça
si j'avais pas su oser est singulière et
vous quel est votre singularité
merci